day in and day out we've been working  with the FAA and regulators around the  world to ensure that we're answering all  of their questions and addressing any  concerns that they may have we're also  supporting our airline customers during  this challenging time and collectively  preparing to return the fleet back to  service safety is sacred in this company  and our people who work in the factories  the engineers who design our airplanes  to all of us in every corner of this  business  safety is simply the top priority in  everything we do that company-wide as  Greg said our first priority is doing  absolutely the right thing and doing  everything to get this airplane safely  returned to service